hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another quiz review this
time we're going to be taking a road
down that we haven't done before this
time we're going to be trying something
we've never done before well this time
we're going to try something stupid
not that the quizzes that we've done
before haven't been stupid that means
they've been about me so of course
they've been stupid so it's a common
joke on the internet the cosmopolitan
doesn't make any sense
both in the advice that they give and in
the quizzes that they have so I'm gonna
follow down these roads because I've
cherry picked just a few quizzes that I
think you guys want to know about me
much like this one which Disney Prince
is your soulmate which animated hunk
will be your babe I think my IQ just
dropped a few points reading that
sentence but either way uh who wouldn't
want to know which guy's my soulmate
which Disney Prince is my soulmate
specifically not just generally which
guy but which Disney Prince and in my
mind it might be this guy this [ __ ]
guy right here this [ __ ] guy I don't
know I know hello you know what does
this get into it what's the worst that
could happen
I don't know embarrass myself on the
internet like that hasn't happened
before
Oh find out some horrible dark secrets
about myself okay here's the first date
spot amusement park a workout class
dinner in a dimly lit restaurant ice
cream sandwiches at sunset helicopter
ride to the Hampton well okay the
amusement park is fine a workout class
is weird dinner in a dimly lit
restaurant why do you have to call the
dimly lit restaurant you can't have it
like romantically lit restaurant has to
be a dish that's a be a a dimly lit
restaurant just a pitch-black restaurant
Lee oh my god
that's a [ __ ] horror movie right
there why is it gotta be so you couldn't
see anything you couldn't see the menu
but on this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going
on here wait what's this Hey hi okay
how's that preparing a beautiful sensory
experience tonight you will be dining in
the dark the lie
hey [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this guy
guys [ __ ] how did you feel you can
have something like it's a time every
day it have this at home whenever you
like because you're eating frozen pizza
tonight no oh [ __ ] off with this
[ __ ] really frozen pizza
I [ __ ] love DiGiorno give me a
goddamn DiGiorno sponsorship anyway ice
cream sandwiches at sunset doesn't makes
it easier cuz that's like the end of the
date helicopter ride to the Hamptons
well it [ __ ] would you want that just
get an amusement park so you can lose
each other if you hate the date what's
the most important quality you look for
in a guy
me me how many Instagram followers he
has yes sir I like it if a guy doesn't
text you back right away what do you do
the spam is focus more texted silly
responds get on with your life you'll
respond money as a minute from blessing
the world with his presence thanks one
of his friends call him sext him that's
a bold move I'm just gonna spam him
non-stop cuz what if they're dead what
if they're in trouble what if they don't
like me which kardashian-jenner sister
do you identify with the most I don't
know any of them ever Kim I don't even
want to know that one why are they all
kidding why are they all caning it
doesn't make any sense
I don't know this is where I'm gonna
horribly embarrass myself I don't know
who these people are I don't know what
I'm doing I'm gonna go with Kendall okay
choose a Froyo topic condensed milk
condensed milk cheesecake cubes that's
pretty good mochi not on like mochi
sorry I've just angered the Internet
haven't I that's right ladies and
gentlemen
what a markiplier nothing like [ __ ]
mochi sorry uh gummy bears rubbers I'll
take the cheesecake cubes these are none
of the actual toppings that I would do
but let's do this
prince charming he's got money the looks
perfect teeth even really he checks off
every box he just doesn't really have a
personality but how perfect is this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't want prince charming who the
[ __ ] is prince charming who gives an ass
about Prince Charming what is my Froyo
topping of anything to do with that
anyway moving on with that quiz you know
get on with your lives I can't I can't I
can't be bothered to know okay does this
sexy body part belong to Luke Liam or
Chris Hemsworth test your Hemsworth
expertise once again brought to you by
Peggy drawing which Hemsworth I'd be
Alec Baldwin and Baldwin
that's Alec Baldwin it's [ __ ] Alec
Baldwin look I'm not joking here
that's [ __ ] Alec Baldwin this
beautiful be little doe-eyed I didn't
know there were three Hemsworth whereas
Alec can I write in Alec Baldwin Liam no
Luke huh Chris okay whoa whoa or this
beautiful chest area uh Luke [ __ ] uh
Chris uh uh Liam uh uh Chris do the top
hey wait a minute don't [ __ ] on me I'm
just gonna bet Chris because he probably
has the most pictures how do I do you
got fifty nine percent correct you're
not an expert and yet not yet a master
your knowledge of the process is not
quite there but keep working on it
you'll get to the promised land of AB
soon that fact is that name what the
[ __ ] is that what does that mean the
promised land of ABS doesn't make any
goddamn sense
who is Luke
who the [ __ ] is this wouldn't forget
that I know they had another one look at
this [ __ ] oh no [ __ ] this one's more
classic cosmopolitan quiz will he be
great in bed
cuz that's what I want to know more than
anything in the world meeting a guy you
like is so freaking exciting but
wondering whether or not he's going to
be able to get you off can be dot dot
dot less exciting take this quiz and
find out if he has the capacity make you
giant and happy and your brain Oh lame
or you are the funniest right Cosmo oh I
bet I bet all these questions are
definitely going to be related to how
good a guy is in bed often does he ask
how your day was all right so me
sometimes but usually we talk about
random stuff how does it feel when he
you in a super casual way it doesn't
happen that often but what it does I
think it's by mistake still it feels
good because he's super hot reassuring
because he doesn't really touch me I
feel like if he did my body would
explode okay that one what's he like on
the dance floor
we've never been dancing but I bet he'd
be pretty alright here's my dancing yeah
get it let me throw a DAB into the mix I
am NOT a dorky but he's trying I think
that's what that is
often does he make fun of you for stupid
little things ever I'm super nice when
he's annoying you and you're like okay
stop it does he stop it
probably not yeah but not before doing
it one more time for good measure yeah
that's it how comfortable do you feel
around him ah this one see a pretty
confident dude yes he definitely knows
how great he is that sounds like me
how's your first kiss I don't know ha ha
ha
yeah yeah that's probably that one how
often does he make serious eye contact
with you oh oh you know oh here and
there
oh yeah so guess is their ego son a
little too long it up like holy hell too
much how do you feel about yourself when
you're around him well I don't know how
to answer this I can't answer this from
my perspective like I'm a really cool
person to know whether or not I feel
super hot depends on the moment but at
least feel like a rad chick how dare
this quiz gender haze [ __ ]
be tough to know until you try Wow oh oh
the answer would have been [ __ ] I don't
know until you [ __ ] do it
of course oh I shouldn't have been a
[ __ ] idiot okay fine this guy clearly
has a lot going to come that the
chemistry let him you communicated he's
open he Stansbury and yet to be stellar
in bed
oh [ __ ] is this [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you're not Valens out of the way we all
feel worse about ourselves
especially me let's go on to something
that can make us feel even worse about
ourselves especially me what is your
true age according to social media
habits by Yves Peyser okay I'm gonna
answer this one honestly and truly as
best I can
I've got the newest iPhone that's fine
how often do you socially post I could
do it more a couple times a day what do
you think of LinkedIn I've never had it
is that what old people from these days
yeah I'm not old yeah if I get this if I
get the age of seven again I'm going to
be [ __ ] pissed all right what's your
favorite social media network
yeah have you ever gone a whole day
without checking your social media oh my
god never I uh
which emojis behold God whoa which emoji
best describes you
the something's up emoji yeah that seems
about right
how did you meet your significant other
ah tinder uh what do you typically
Instagram selfies with my friends
Sophie's by myself yeah pretty much
pretty much exclusively selfies nothing
but that what app could you not live
without ah I could theoretically live
without all my maps ah I know Instagram
is pretty important to me so I'm a good
bag what's the most embarrassing thing
you can post on Sophie's social media
one of my nudes an ugly selfie a
screenshot on my bank account I'm not
easily embarrassed yeah I'm not easily
embarrassed now those would be terribly
bad for me you are 14 ah ah
I'm 14 you hear that guys 14 year old
mark EMU coming through the door ah I
doubled my age since the last thing that
I did so I guess that's something to
look forward to
alright that's a Cosmo quiz that's a big
bag of asses if that's everything I'm
gonna go shoot my computer now hey I'm
sorry I make you go through that I'm
sorry I have to end this before it
spreads no one take any of these quizzes
I'm the only one qualified to be able to
survive it but my computer is infected
with the stupid so I'm going to end this
once and for all so let me know down in
the comments if you want to see another
one of these I don't know if I want to
do it but I need another computer before
I do because this one's going out the
window so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
[Music]
you